[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to hate it I love it The Game of
Thrones finale has been a big talking
point over the last week and the end of
the season left enough plot threads
dangling that opens up the universe to
the possibility of so many more
adventures with several spin-offs
rumored to be coming in the next couple
of years I thought I'd break down
everything we know so far about the new
shows their settings and what could
happen in them
this is full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't seen the finale of Game of
Thrones and aren't fully up to speed
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now with that out the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
Game of Thrones spin-off breakdown okay
so the first show that we have confirmed
is a prequel to the season though it
would have been amazing if they just
called it Game of Thrones the show looks
like it's going to be named at the long
night fans of Game of Thrones will know
that the legendary long night saw the
battle between the forces of ancient
Westeros and the White Walkers over
5,000 years before the events of the
main series this is set during a time
period known as the Golden Age of Heroes
and it shows the descent of society into
the dark ages whilst the majority of the
cast weren't alive at this point there
is one character who will make an
appearance and that is the night king
the series is set to tell his true
origin story and will be set during the
time period that the children of the
forest made a pact with the first man in
the main series brand traveled back to
this period to witness the birth of the
night king and it's also during this age
of the Starks ancestor bran the Builder
created the Great Wall and Winterfell
HBO has also began pulling together the
cast of the show with Naomi Watts set to
be its main star though we all saw what
happened to Ned Stark at the end of
season one she is speculated to be Nissa
Nissa the wife of legendary hero Azure a
high which I can never pronounce so
sorry if I got that wrong he was of
course a famous warrior that many
speculated was reincarnated as Jon Snow
in addition to this miranda Richardson
Jamie Campbell Bower Jon
sym and Georgie Henley have all been
cast though their roles are not
confirmed yet all in all I'm pretty
excited for this and now it's a prequel
that the show could shed a lot of light
on the unanswered questions at the end
of season 8 and hopefully it adds more
texture to the highly divisive series
the prequel is due to be released
roughly around May 20-22 peal it for the
series already filming hopefully we will
see this as soon as possible and with a
budget set to match season 8 of Game of
Thrones it could definitely rival the
original the next spin-off comes in the
form of an area-based solo show that
fans are affectionately calling re-aired
the Explorium
those who've seen the final episode will
know that she sailed west of Westeros
which I really hope is called rester
offs this is because no one has been
there yet and she wants to be the first
one to map it whilst HBO bosses are
staunchly denying that the show will be
greenlit with programming chief Casey
Blois flat-out denying it in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
yesterday you can't help but feel like a
fans drum up enough support and
interested that they will go with it a
flat-out don't believe Casey and ask me
again in 10 years if he was right
because this is too hot of a property
not to do area was one of the only
characters that still remain popular
after the finale so it would be a great
direction to take
Aria really came into her own in the
final season and she's still yet to shut
those green eyes so hopefully the show
is greenlit and we can see what the
world is like far beyond Westeros in
addition to this george RR martin let's
slip that there were originally five
scripts being looked at with v being
shelved this means potentially that we
could have for game of thrones spin-off
shows down the line hell we may even get
the petition rewrite of season a which
I'd love to see even though I know it
never will actually think season 8
leaves so many plot threads dangling
that there could be so much more down
the line in that season hopefully right
drogon carries Danny's body north of the
wall and right listening he drops her
body down on something that we've just
made up right now so that she can come
back to life and then she's resurrected
by guess who none other than the bloody
night king and we can just get season 9
made
forget forget all this ever happened so
yeah once that petition gets done just
hand me the keys and I'll sort it all
out I won't hold my breath though
obviously I love to hear your thoughts
on the spin-offs and what you hope to
see in them comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the final episode of
the series which would be linked at the
end we've also just launched a merch
section on the channel so if you want to
support the show and get something back
from it make sure you click the boxes
and links below
it all goes towards making these videos
better and it's massively appreciated so
thank you this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time
take care peace
[Music]